Europa ringt um eine gemeinsame Antwort
auf Putins Krieg einen Monat haben wir
hinter den Kulissen verfolgt wie der
Streit um Waffen das Bündnis zu spalten
droht
jetzt Imperativ es ist alternativlos der
Ukraine alle Waffen zu geben die sie
braucht um ihr Land zurückzuerobern
ein Jahr Krieg hat große Teile der
Ukraine versüßtet von Dörfern bleiben
nur Trümmern
unser Haus wurde komplett zerstört dabei
ist unsere Familie zu neunt
die Sehnsucht nach Frieden ist riesig
und die Hoffnungen gehen noch weiter
Krieg zu Ende ist werden wir der EU
beitreten die USA sind die größten
Waffenlieferanten doch Amerikas radikale
Rechte will ein Ende der Unterstützung
unter republikanischer Führung wird
Penny mehr an die Ukraine gehen der
Krieg stellt die Einheit des Westens auf
die Probe
ich sorge mich eher dass Europas
Entschlossenheit bröckelt genau das
könnte das Ziel des Herrschers im Kreml
sein
[Musik]
das Außenministerium in Vilnius von hier
bestimmt Litauen seine Politik im Kampf
gegen Russland in den Gängen spürt man
die Solidarität mit der Ukraine von hier
warnen sie vor der russischen Gefahr und
fürchten die nächsten zu sein die Putin
angreifen will
gabrielius Landsberg es ist der
Außenminister der Kampf der Ukraine sei
der Kampf der freien Welt das ist seine
Botschaft die er nicht müde wird zu
wiederholen
an diesem Tag ist er sehr zufrieden denn
Deutschland hat kurz vorher in der
panzerfrage eingelenkt und den Weg
verlieferungen freigemacht darf ich
Ihnen etwas zeigen es gibt nun ein
breites Bündnis aus Europäern und den
USA
seine Freude darüber hat er gleich
geteilt das ist sehr gut angekommen bei
Twitter
sie haben das getwittert
auf die Entscheidung habe ich so lange
gewartet
Landsbergs und die anderen Osteuropäer
haben hart für diese Entscheidung
gekämpft haben Streit in Europa in Kauf
genommen es muss sein sagt er
wenn wir darüber reden was die
wirkungsvollsten Waffen sind dann sind
das Kampfpanzer bis heute umso mehr wir
schicken desto besser
wir haben Landsberg es ein Monat
begleitet ein wichtiger Monat in dem
Europa darum ringt eine gemeinsame
Haltung zu finden die Frage der
Bewaffnung der Ukraine droht die EU zu
spalten Landsbergs wird in dieser Zeit
zum Mahner zum Antreiber und zu einem
Gegenspieler des deutschen
Bundeskanzlers
[Musik]
einmal im Jahr verwandelt sich die
Promenade des skiorts Davos in das
Zentrum der Weltwirtschaft
dort wo normalerweise die Touristen
einkaufen und Feiern präsentieren sich
die Finanzgiganten die unser aller Leben
bestimmen
Landsberg ist nach Davos eingeladen eine
Bühne die er nutzt um zu testen ob die
freie Welt wirklich hinter der Ukraine
steht der Krieg verlangt von den
Partnern und von deren Bevölkerung viel
wie lange noch ist die Verteidigung der
Ukraine Europas Schicksal
das hier ist ein herausragender Ort um
viele Menschen zu treffen
meine Botschaft an sie ist einfach
fühlen wir uns wirklich der Ukraine
verpflichtet
meinen wir das ernst
denn wir in Litauen haben die Angst dass
die Unterstützung der Ukraine nachlassen
könnte
im idyllischen Skiort diskutieren sie
über eine nie dagewesene Anhäufung von
Problemen Energie Wirtschaft Klimakrise
und der Krieg die Stimmung in Davos ist
düster sie sprechen von der Gefahr dass
die Welt unter den multi-krisen
zusammenbricht
Bundeskanzler Scholz lächelt viel in
Davos aber zu den Panzerlieferungen will
er Mitte Januar nicht sagen Scholz hat
sein eigenes Entscheidungs Tempo
landsbergers warnt hingegen vor der
Gefahr eines Atomschlags der Ukraine
Krieg bekommt bei ihm eine
apokalyptische Dimension er kann und
will nicht mehr auf Deutschland warten
will zur Zeiten Wände Taten sehen
die Erwartungen an die Zeiten Wände
setzt Deutschland unter Druck
diejenigen die sie ausgerufen haben
hatten wohl gehofft sie hätten ein
jahrzehn Zeit sie umzusetzen
aber wir brauchen ein Deutschland das
jetzt führt für die Ostflanke für
Litauen für die Ukraine
wir brauchen Deutschland um Europa
Sicherheit zu garantieren
im Saal redet Scholz fast eine Stunde
ohne das Wort Panzer in den Mund zu
nehmen erst die Regie des
Weltwirtschaftsforums zwingt den
Bundeskanzler sich zu erklären ein
ukrainischer Journalist stellt die Frage
auf deren Antwort alle gewartet haben
die westlichen Verbündeten und Amerika
sind bereit die Kampfpanzer zu liefern
warum zögert und wartet Deutschland
wir werden vermeiden dass es einen Krieg
zwischen der Nato und Russland gibt
das ist auch im Interesse der Ukraine
das sagen sie mir immer wieder
die Angst vor den Russen kennt
Landsbergs nur zu gut sein Land hat
lange unter der Sowjetunion gelitten
dies hat seine Kindheit geprägt nun muss
er den Schrecken seinen Kindern erklären
wenn man einem 14-jährigen erklären muss
was da gerade passiert und warum so nah
ist und ob es auch in unserem Land
passieren könnte
ehrlich gesagt ich hätte niemals
geglaubt dass ich so etwas in meinem
Leben mal erklären muss
wir werden landsberges Ende Januar in
Brüssel wieder treffen wo er den Druck
auf die Bundesregierung weiter erhöht
wie sieht es aus an den Frontlinien
dieses Krieges der seit einem Jahr die
weltbeschäftigt ich habe mich aufgemacht
in ein Gebiet an der russischen Grenze
zu einer Einheit der ukrainischen
Territorialverteidigung die Stellung
liegt auf offenem Feld die russischen
Truppen sind nur einen Kilometer
entfernt
der Kommandant geht voran und mir wird
klar auch in diesen schlammigen
Schützengräben wird der Krieg
entschieden
von einem Aussichtspunkt können Sie die
russischen Stellungen beobachten und was
tun Sie wenn die angreifen wird dann
schlagen wir zurück mit unseren Waffen
und das ist was das ist ein
Maschinengewehr ein altes sowjetisches
Maschinengewehr zur Verteidigung die
Waffen der Männer zeigen deutlich wie
unzureichend sie für diesen Kampf
ausgerüstet sind
und was passiert wenn es ernst wird
erlebe ich kurze Zeit später
russische Artillerie feuert auf die
Stellung alle drängen schnell in den
Schutzbunker unter der Erde
hier ist alles vorhanden sogar eine
Küche denn manchmal müssen sie hier
lange aushalten notfalls sogar über
Nacht
wir haben nicht viele Waffen es fehlt
auch Munition westliche Waffen würden
uns sehr helfen
Panzer mörserie alles was man zur
Verteidigung braucht
westliche Waffen machen also einen
großen Unterschied in diesem Krieg
natürlich ohne Waffen hätte die Ukraine
schwerer
mit Hilfe unserer westlichen Partner
sind wir durchschlagskräftiger
bereits zu Beginn des Krieges hatte der
ukrainische Präsident wurde mir selenski
sich immer wieder an die westliche
Staatengemeinschaft gewendet mit der
Bitte um militärische Unterstützung
Munition
Transportfahrzeuge Schützenpanzer
Artillerie und zuletzt auch
Kampfflugzeuge
erstmals in der Geschichte der NATO
erhält ein Land das dem Bündnis nicht
angehört eine so breite militärische
Unterstützung doch es ist auch mühsames
Ringen um jede Lieferung dabei drängt
die Zeit für die Ukraine
in Kiew treffe ich den Vorsitzenden des
nationalen Sicherheitsrates olexie
Danilov er gehört zu dem kleinen Kreis
der Männer die in diesem Krieg eine
wichtige Rolle spielen
die ganze zivilisierte Welt ist heute an
unserer Seite
wie sollen wir nicht gewinnen wir siegen
bestimmt wird es schwierig sein ja es
wird schwierig sein weil der Krieg an
sich eine schwierige Situation ist Putin
hat null Chancen und das sage ich nicht
nur für das Interview er kann nicht
gegen die ganze Welt kämpfen
an seinem Computer wieder Krieg bisher
verlaufen ist er ruft das Bild des
ersten Tages auf des 24 Februar 2022 an
dem Russland aus allen Richtungen die
Ukraine Angriff ein bedrohliches
Szenario damals so sagt danielow dachten
alle Länder der Welt dass die Ukraine
innerhalb weniger Tage den Krieg
verlieren würden
alles ist anders gekommen dieses Schema
zeigt die aktuelle Situation in bachmut
der heftig umkämpften Stadt im Osten der
Ukraine
es sind vermutlich die bislang
heftigsten Kämpfe in diesem Krieg in
bachmut zeigt sich welchen hohen Preis
ukrainische Soldaten zahlen um die
russischen Angriffe abzuwehren westliche
Waffen die dringend gebraucht werden
kommen hier zu spät
an einer Stellung nahe der Frontlinie
bei bachmut ist eine der 14
Panzerhaubitzen im Einsatz die
Deutschland im Sommer des vergangenen
Jahres geliefert hat
auch wenn es mit großen Risiken
verbunden ist ermöglicht die Armee uns
hier zu drehen und mit Soldaten zu
sprechen sie alle wurden in Deutschland
ausgebildet
Techniker die Technik ist gut geht aber
auf kaputt was Deutschland angeht das
war super alles hat mir gut gefallen man
hat uns geschult die Leute sind gut
sehr positiv ich will aber dass wir noch
mehr davon bekommen wir mehr dann
beenden wir diesen Krieg damit das alles
zu Ende geht ich danke Deutschland dass
das Land uns hilft
sie brauchen mehr als die
Panzerhaubitzen die Deutschland und die
Niederlande bislang geliefert haben um
die Angriffe der Russen abwehren zu
können auch fehlt es ihnen an
Ersatzteilen und Munition die Zeit
spielt in bachmut gegen die Ukraine
dennoch sind die Soldaten sicher Sie
werden den Krieg gewinnen
in hakiff haben amerikanische Soldaten
ein Trainingszentrum gegründet um
ukrainische Soldaten auszubilden die
Trainer sind freiwillige die meisten
kommen aus den USA
das Hauptziel ist ukrainischen Soldaten
einen standardisiertes Training zukommen
zu lassen Basiswissen sie bekommen
spezialisiertes Wissen im Umgang mit
westlichen Waffen wenn sie nach Polen
oder Deutschland gehen aber sie
benötigen Basiswissen auf Infanterie
Ebene
Rodi ist einer der Freiwilligen die für
die Organisation Trident Arbeiten er war
schon in vielen Kriegen und möchte seine
Erfahrung weitergeben die meisten von
ihm ausgebildeten Soldaten kämpfen
bereits im Osten des Landes viele
bereits seit einem Jahr rudi ist
überzeugt dass die Ukraine den Krieg für
sich entscheiden werden mit dem Ziel
alle von Russland besetzten Gebiete
zurückzuerobern
besonders mit den westlichen Waffen mit
Panzern und all dem was jetzt ins Land
kommt in Verbindung mit dem Training
dass wir in unserer Gruppe durchführen
und auch im ganzen Land wird es sich
lohnen
sie sind siegesgewiss solange der Westen
sie weiter unterstützt mit Ausbildung
Waffen und Munition
New York City Welthauptstadt und Sitz
der Vereinten Nationen ein Schmelztiegel
der Kulturen an der amerikanischen
Ostküste es ist Mitte Januar im East
Village Downton Manhattan sieht eine
Gruppe der ukrainischen Diaspora durch
die Straßen
sie singen orthodoxe Weihnachtslieder
alle haben Verwandte in der Ukraine auch
hier geht der Krieg an die Substanz
Irena ist Krankenschwester in New York
plant im März mal ein paar Ärzten in die
Ukraine zu gehen
es gibt Kriegsmüdigkeit eine emotionale
Erschöpfung
auch bei mir
deshalb ist es so wichtig über die
Feiertage neue Energie zu tanken denn
wir müssen weitermachen
wir Ukrainer sind so dankbar für jeden
einzelnen Menschen der uns unterstützt
hat uns weiterhin unterstützt und
unterstützen wird und ich hoffe dass es
noch viele solcher Menschen geben wird
denn die Menschen in der Ukraine werden
nicht aufgeben
[Musik]
Irenas große Sorge ist es dass die
weltweite Unterstützung der Ukraine
langsam abnehmen könnte umso wichtiger
sei es alles zu tun um auf das Leid im
Land und das Schicksal seiner Menschen
aufmerksam zu machen
kurzes Aufwärmen mittags im Stretch
einem einfachen sehr ursprünglichen
ukrainischen Restaurant bei Bosch und
Kohlrouladen treffen wir Julia schamer
sie arbeitet ehrenamtlich für rason eine
ukrainische Hilfsorganisation hier in
New York die Ukraine brauche gerade
jetzt ein Jahr nach der russischen
Invasion mehr Hilfe denn je sagt sie
im Haus der Ukraine gleich nebenan zeigt
uns Julia nach dem Mittagessen woran sie
gerade arbeitet mit den vielen
freiwilligen das die Unterstützung
abnehme sieht sie zumindest hier in den
USA noch nicht so recht
ich persönlich treffe viele Menschen die
noch nie etwas von der Ukraine gehört
haben oder die sich anfangs nicht dafür
interessiert haben doch jetzt wollen Sie
wissen was los ist sie möchten mehr über
die Ukraine erfahren sie sind
interessiert sie fragen wie sie der
Ukraine helfen können diese
Unterstützung ist ein Schlüssel den
Krieg in der Ukraine zu beenden
auf einem großen Tisch Tablets und
merkwürdige Geräte die auf den ersten
Blick aussehen wie Rasierapparate mobile
Ultraschallgeräte die sich auf den
Tablets einrichten
100 solche Einheiten haben sie gerade
als Spender erhalten werd etwa 300.000
Dollar bevor dann alle seni Ukraine geht
werden die Einheiten getestet alles gut
du wirst 120 Jahre alt klar ganz
bestimmt
warum sind denn diese Geräte hier so
wichtig wie die Ukraine im Moment
also zunächst werden diese Geräte bei
Notfällen an der Front eingesetzt
um zu sehen wie ernst eine Verletzung
ist
zum Beispiel bei Hämatomen bei
Brustverletzungen oder wenn die Lunge
betroffen ist
wenn so wichtige Organe wie Leber oder
Milz verletzt sind kann es zu großem
Blutverlust kommen und man kann daran
sterben
mobile Ultraschallgeräte für die Sanität
Soldaten und feldlazaretta an der Front
Hightech die dabei helfen soll den Krieg
zu gewinnen nicht nur für die Ukraine
wenn wir nicht gewinnen dann könnten
auch weitere Länder in einen Krieg
verwickelt werden wenn sich niemand mehr
an das Gesetz hält wenn es keine
Konsequenzen hätte das Völkerrecht zu
brechen
mehr als 70 Millionen Dollar haben
US-Bürger seit der russischen Invasion
gespendet noch kommen immer neue Spenden
herein doch in den USA scheint etwas in
Bewegung zu geraten
noch steht nach den jüngsten Umfragen
eine klare Mehrheit der Amerikaner
hinter der Unterstützung für die Ukraine
bei den Anhängern der Republikaner aber
nimmt die Unterstützung deutlich ab
nachdem die Republikaner bei den
middramen eine knappe mehr dem
US-Kongress zurückerobert hatten ließ
der neue Sprecher des US-Kongresses
Kevin McCarthy verlauten das ist für die
Ukraine unter republikanische
haushaltshoheit keinen blankoschek mehr
geben werden wohl auch um die
Extremisten aus dem Trump Lager
einzufangen die machen kräftig Stimmung
gegen weitere Hilfe für die Ukraine
unter republikanischer Führung wird kein
Penny mehr an die Ukraine gehen
unser Land kommt zuerst
I will ich werde es nicht unterstützen
weiteres Geld an die Ukraine zu geben
präsidente lensky will sein Land und
seine Leute schützen ist mir klar aber
ich wünschte mir unser Präsident würde
das gleiche tun und unsere Grenze im
Süden und unsere Leute schützen
es ist lächerlich dass wir uns auf diese
Grenze in der Ukraine fokussieren mir
ist es völlig egal was mit der Ukraine
passiert
wir haben uns mit John Bolton verabredet
Boden ist bestens vernetzt in der
republikanischen Partei wir wollen von
ihm wissen was davon zu halten ist dass
immer mehr republikanische Politiker
fordern die Ukraine nicht immer weiter
zu unterstützen
Bolton ist ein berüchtigter
republikanische Hardliner ein Falke war
unter George W Bush UN-Botschafter und
nationaler Sicherheitsberater unter
Donald Trump
viel heiße Luft würden einige in seiner
Partei der gerade Blasen Amerikas
Unterstützung der Ukraine werde nicht
wanken
die Unterstützung in der amerikanischen
Bevölkerung ist nach wie vor sehr groß
ich glaube dass das Virus des
Isolationismus sowohl bei den Demokraten
als auch bei den Republikanern wieder
auftaucht es ist aber immer noch eine
deutliche Minderheit die sich von
falschen Vorstellungen ernährt
einige von ihnen stammen von Donald
Trump von seinem Missverständnis über
die Ukraine dass sie ein korruptes Land
sei dessen Bürger sich gegen seine Wahl
2016 und später seine Wiederwahl
verschwören hätten
ich mache mir keine Sorgen darüber dass
die amerikanische Unterstützung bröckelt
aber ich denke es braucht eine bessere
Führung als bisher ehrlich gesagt mache
ich mir mehr Sorgen dass Europas
Entschlossenheit bröckelt
nach wie vor sind die USA die mit
Abstand größten unterstütze der Ukraine
kein Land liefert mehr Geld und Waffen
mehr als alle europäischen Staaten
zusammen
Putin habe Deutschland und Frankreich
die beiden größten Volkswirtschaften der
EU als Schwachstelle in der Allianz
ausgemacht mein Boden
ich denke er glaubt dass einige
europäische Volkswirtschaften wie die
deutsche und die französische einen
Schlussstrich ziehen und wieder zur
Tagesordnung übergehen wollen ich denke
er glaubt dass der wirtschaftliche Druck
in Verbindung mit dem Winter
Auswirkungen auf Europa haben könnte ich
hoffe es nicht aber wenn dieser Krieg
nächstes Jahr weitergeht wird es
vielleicht doch passieren angesichts der
patzsituation in der Ukraine versuchte
Grammel politisch zu gewinnen was er auf
dem Schlachtfeld nicht gewinnen kann
weil er den Krieg militärisch kaum
gewinnen könne Versuche Wladimir Putin
ein Keil zwischen die USA und Europa zu
treiben so wie schon seine Vorgänge in
der Sowjetunion
um die Allianz zu schwächen
Erbauer auf den tief verwurzelten
Anti-Amerikanismus in Europa
um Amerika als den eigentlichen
Aggressor zu beschuldigen
ich denke dass die russische
propagandamaschinei das sicherlich
unterstützt aber in der Geschichte hat
es nie eine amerikanische Aggression in
Europa gegeben die einzige Aggression
gegenüber Europa war eine auf die wir
geantwortet haben deshalb bin ich froh
dass wir diese Debatte führen wenn die
Menschen in Europa Amerika nicht mehr
wollen und das auch sagen glauben sie
mir dann würde Amerika gerne gehen das
ist eine Gefahr für Europa sie werden
uns vermissen wenn wir nicht mehr da
sind
zurück in New York bei der ukrainischen
Hilfsorganisation rasum junge russische
Schauspielerin Mascha hilft mit die
Ultraschallgeräte für die Front in der
Ukraine vorzubereiten und zu verpacken
sie hilft weil sie sich schämt was aus
ihrem Land geworden ist
ich sehe Russland als einen
terroristischen Staat und es ist unsere
Verantwortung als Russen alles dafür zu
tun diesen System entgegenzutreten
warum denn so viele Russen das ganz
anders sehen würden fragen wir Sie auch
die die nicht in Russland leben würden
sie sehen keine westlichen Medien ihre
einzige Informationsquelle sind
russische Medien die sie mit falschen
Informationen versorgen
meist ist das was die russische
Propaganda über die Ukraine verbreitet
genau das Gegenteil nämlich das was Sie
selber tun sie geben sich so selbst
Preis
Propaganda und Desinformation sein für
Russland zu einer scharfen Waffe in
diesem Krieg geworden erzählen Sie uns
hier in New York immer wieder und wir
werden später auch hier bei den
Vereinten Nationen erfahren wie absurd
so manche Geschichten sind
mitten im europa-viertel in Brüssel in
der sechsten Etage eines unscheinbaren
Bürogebäudes sitzt eine Gruppe von
EU-Beamten und kämpft gegen Russlands
Propaganda
ihr Chef ist Lutz Güllner er will nicht
dass wir seine Mitarbeiter zeigen um
Ihre Identität zu schützen treffen wir
ihn draußen
das ist noch eine Arbeit die natürlich
gegen auch staatliche Akteure geht das
sind Geheimdienste am Werk es geht ja
dann auch um das dann ihre Konten auf
einmal überlaufen mit mit Hassmails und
und ähnlichen all das kann passieren und
davor würde ich meine Mitarbeiter gerne
und Mitarbeiterinnen gerne schützen
Europa hat eine Weile gebraucht den
Krieg um die Wahrheit ernst zu nehmen
seit der Annektion der Krim lässt die EU
gülner und sein Team russische
Propaganda auswerten um Putins
Informationskrieg sichtbar zu machen
das Massaker in der ukrainischen
stadtbuscher Eindrücke die nur schwer zu
ertragen sind
kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen war das Grauen ins Gesicht
geschrieben als sie bei ihrem Besuch die
Verbrechen an der Zivilbevölkerung sah
Putins Regierung begann sofort damit
Verwirrung zu stiften und die Spuren zu
verwischen sie beschuldigte die Ukraine
das Massaker mit Schauspielern
inszeniert zu haben dies Erzählung
übernahmen die russischen Medien Medien
wie newsfront die dem Kreml nahestehen
ein ganz wichtiger Fall den wir immer
wieder sehen ist dass man gar nicht
sozusagen ein narrativ und dann das
gegen narrativ dazu hat also die eine
Meinung und die gegen Meinung sondern
dass man viele andere narrative in die
Welt setzt so dass dann am Ende die
Zuschauer oder die die die die
Adressaten sozusagen am Ende so viele
verschiedene Versionen von einer von
einer Begebenheit sehen dass er
eigentlich gar keiner Quelle mehr trauen
genau das ist Putins Ziel die Grenzen
zwischen Wahrheit und Lüge zu verwischen
Misstrauen zu sehen dann haben seine
kruden Vorwürfe die Chance geklappt zu
werden
denn Putin legitimiert den Einmarsch in
die Ukraine damit das Land von Nazis
befreien zu wollen
diese
grafikveranschaulicht wie häufig die
russische Propaganda den nazi-vorwurf
erhoben hat interessant zeitgleich mit
der militärischen Mobilmachung kurz vor
dem Krieg rüstet auch die Propaganda auf
der nazi-vorwurf häuft sich sie sehen
den großen Anstieg dieser Kurve gerade
ab Dezember und ab Dezember wurden
massiv Truppen an die ukrainische Grenze
verlegt das heißt man hat begonnen
sozusagen das konnte man damals
natürlich noch nicht als automotivismus
ablesen aber im rückblickend kann man
durchaus sagen dass die militärische
Mobilmachung eindeutig auch Hand in Hand
ging mit einer informationellen mobil
machen
als Reporter in Brüssel erleben wir wie
der Ukraine Krieg Europa grundlegend
verändert die zeitenwände deckt
Lebenslügen auf Europa kann sich nicht
ohne Hilfe der USA verteidigen es muss
lernen sich selbst um seine Sicherheit
zu kümmern das ist unstrittig nur über
das Tempo gibt es
Meinungsverschiedenheiten
[Musik]
gabrielius Landsbergs hat es eilig ein
Politiker in Kriegszeiten der
Außenminister Litauens fordert
unermüdlich mehr Waffen für die Ukraine
aber erst einmal stoppt ihn das
eu-protokoll und gibt ihm
Regieanweisungen für den roten Teppich
die dritte Kamera ist ihre
sie können sie nicht verfehlen der
Kameramann winkt ihnen sie können jetzt
gehen
[Musik]
seinen Auftritt seine Worte hat er sich
gut überlegt in Europa spürt er
Kriegsmüdigkeit Zweifel an immer neuen
Waffenlieferungen vor allem bei den
Deutschen dagegen redet er an
es ist alternativlos der Ukraine alle
Waffen zu geben die sie benötigt um ihr
Land zurückzuerobern
es ist Ende Januar die Debatte um
Panzerlieferungen an die Ukraine
begleitet Landsbergs bei jedem
eu-treffen er ist auf dem Weg zum Rad
der EU-Außenminister dort erwarten ihn
seine Kollegen einige wie die Deutschen
mögen sein unermüdliches fordern nach
Leopard Panzer nicht aber er erhöht
weiter den
Drucker was ist ihre Botschaft an die
Deutschen
vielen Dank für das was sie bisher für
uns getan haben ich weiß das ist ihnen
nicht leicht gefallen ich weiß um die
politischen Debatten und Ängste in
Deutschland aber wir müssen weiter
Waffen liefern wir dürfen nicht
nachlassen
er wird nicht müde zu fordern
das nervt sie obwohl Außenministerin
baerbock ist generell nicht gegen die
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern anders als
der Bundeskanzler noch beerburg muss
deshalb ihre Sätze genau wählen das Wort
Panzer nimmt sie nicht mehr in den Mund
beschwört Geschlossenheit deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass wir als
internationale Partner gemeinsam
vorgehen bei der Unterstützung und dem
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung der Ukraine
vielen Dank weitere Fragen unerwünscht
Landsbergs wird Sie oben in der Sitzung
dennoch stellen vielen Osteuropäern
gelten vor allem die Deutschen als
Bremser Entscheidungen zur
Waffenlieferungen fehlen zu langsam das
ist der Vorwurf von Landsbergs
Deutschland ist von der ständigen Kritik
genervt die Sitzung wird hitzig der
Ukraine Krieg droht Europa zu spalten
draußen auf dem Platz vor dem
Ratsgebäude singen sie die ukrainische
Nationalhymne und hoffen dass sie
drinnen gehört werden
es sind überwiegend Exil Ukraine die
sich hier versammelt haben und lautstark
Waffen für die Ukraine fordern
eine von ihnen ist Jana POF die sie kam
für das Studium nach Brüssel aber der
Krieg hat auch ihr Leben
durcheinandergewirbelt nun ist sie eine
von zigtausenden von Ukrainern die im
Ausland für den Sieg ihres Landes
kämpfen ihre Väter Ehemänner Brüder und
Söhne sind an der Front sowie der Vater
von Jana
mein Vater hat mich gefragt warum
schicken sie keine Leopard-Panzer und
ehrlich gesagt ich hatte darauf keine
Antwort
Hunderttausende von Soldaten in der
Ukraine sind enttäuscht sie brauchen
diese Waffen denn dieses Jahr wird noch
schrecklicher als das erste Jahr
Brüssel am Abend die Außenminister sind
abgereist die Demonstranten abgezogen
aber die Kritik an den deutschen bleibt
sie droht die Einigkeit Europas zu
gefährden das wäre ganz im Sinne Putins
[Applaus]
der Krieg hat Spuren hinterlassen
überall im Land wo einst Dörfer waren
sind nur noch Trümmer geblieben
ich bin unterwegs auf der Landstraße
zwischen isum und krematorsk in der
Region Donezk und ich frage mich wie
sollen hier noch Menschen leben
in easium wird das ganze Ausmaß der
Zerstörung mitten im Zentrum deutlich
Wohnhäuser die unbewohnbar sind wo
herausgerissene Fassaden den Blick
freigeben auf das Leben das ist hier
einmal gab
im September hatten ukrainische Truppen
hier die Russen vertrieben doch auf die
Erleichterung und Freude folgte schnell
Ernüchterung 80% der Gebäude sind
zerstört isium gleicht einer
Geisterstadt
als deutsche Reporterin treffe ich auf
Menschen die immer wieder auch
Dankbarkeit äußern wenn ich nach ihrer
Lage Frage
es ist schwer und wir danken euch
Deutschland dass ihr uns zur Seite steht
dass Ihr uns helft sowohl materiell als
auch moralisch dass die humanitäre Hilfe
kommt wir sind euch sehr dankbar
doch vor allem im Osten der Ukraine in
Städten wie easium wird mir immer wieder
klar der Krieg hat den Menschen die
Lebensgrundlage genommen es sind vor
allem die alten und Armen die geblieben
sind und ihre Zukunftsperspektiven sind
düster wer soll die Häuser wieder
aufbauen die zerstört wurden viele
Menschen werden noch über viele Jahre im
Ausnahmezustand leben müssen
nur mit internationaler Unterstützung
ist es den Ukrainern möglich die
Bevölkerung zu versorgen in irpin hat
eine polnische Hilfsorganisation
Container aufgestellt in solchen
provisorischen Unterkünften leben
Menschen überall im Land
neben den Containern ist eine ehemalige
Schule zur Anlaufstelle umfunktioniert
worden hier stehen Köche jeden Tag am
Herd um Essen für die zuzubereiten die
sich nicht mehr selbst versorgen können
Weltküche nennt sich die Initiative auch
sie finanziert sich vor allem mit
Spenden aus dem Ausland gerne möchten
sie uns zeigen dass die Hilfe ankommt
deswegen haben sie uns an diesem Tag
eingeladen beim Mittagessen dabei zu
sein wer sind die Menschen die herkommen
sie leben in einer sehr schlechten
Situation ohne zu Hause ohne Familie
ohne Geld ohne Unterstützung für ihr
Leben
1000 Essen kochen sie alleine hier jeden
Tag
das Problem in unserer Region und in der
Ukraine sind die massiven Stromausfälle
ich habe sogar meinen Kühlschrank
ausgeschaltet und er ist komplett leer
wir würden gerne unser Haus wieder
aufbauen
es wurde total zerstört und wir sind
neun Menschen in der Familie
Bürgermeister Vitali Klitschko wirbt
unermüdlich vor allem in Deutschland um
Unterstützung für seine Stadt und er
sorgt dafür dass die Spenden
öffentlichkeitswirksam vorgeführt werden
an diesem Morgen sind Generatoren aus
Dänemark sechs Polizeiautos und ein
Transporter aus Bayern angekommen
sie holen wir haben von unseren Freunden
Hilfe erhalten die so dringend gebraucht
wird
Generatoren die nicht nur Elektrizität
bringen die werden auch für die
Wärmeversorgung eingesetzt denn wir
werden sie in Wärmekraftwerken
installieren
Ski setzt auch der Bürgermeister von
Kiew auf schnelle Videobotschaften der
Dank an die Spender geht per Smartphone
nach München wir sehen sehr viele Autos
was gerade aus Bayern gekommen deswegen
noch die ganz gerne bedanke für
Unterstützung für die Hilfe sehr sehr
wichtig für uns wirken wir bedanken und
unsere
Polizisten bekommen das Autos und werden
das benutzen wie wichtig ist die
Unterstützung aus dem Westen für seine
Stadt möchte ich wissen und wird genug
getan ohne Hilfe von unserer Partner
können wir nicht überleben
deswegen das ist lebenswichtig für uns
Hilfe zu bekommen die Ukraine haben ihr
Schicksal mit dem Westen verbunden das
ist überall spürbar dabei geht es nicht
nur um die Unterstützung im Krieg auch
die Zukunft ihres Landes sieht die
Mehrheit in Europa immer wieder erstaunt
mich mit welcher Überzeugung sie ihr
Land schon bald in der Europäischen
Union sehen
alle Kriege enden wir wissen das ich
weiß nicht ob es helfen wird oder uns in
fremden wird von der EU aber wenn der
Krieg zu Ende ist werden wir der EU
beitreten
ich denke die Perspektive ist sehr
konkret nicht vernebelt wie vorher weil
wir einen europäisches Land werden
wir machen die richtigen Reformen und
ich denke in naher Zukunft werden wir
der EU beitreten noch ein oder zwei
Jahre dann sind wir da
an symbolischen Auftritten und großen
Gesten fehlt es nicht das ist volodimir
selensky gelungen ist Europa und die
westliche Welt zusammenzubringen sein
Land in diesem Krieg zu unterstützen es
ist eine historische Leistung dass eine
ganze Delegation von eu-kommissaren und
der Ratspräsident in ein Kriegsgebiet
reist kann der ukrainische Präsident
durchaus als Erfolg feiern bei seiner
Reise nach Brüssel machte er jetzt noch
einmal klar worum es den Ukrainern geht
neben der aktuellen Unterstützung im
Krieg sind es die Zukunftsperspektiven
Kurs der Weg in die europäische
Integration ist eine fundamentale
sicherheitsangelegenheit ein freies
Europa ist nicht vorstellbar ohne eine
freie Ukraine ich bin dankbar dass wir
gemeinsam den Status der Ukraine für
einen Beitritt in die EU vorbereitet
haben
die Erwartungen der Ukraine an den
Westen sind hoch das Land in die
Bündnisse der westlichen Welt zu
integrieren das ist das Ziel auf das sie
nach Kriegsende hoffen
auf dem Weg zu einer möglichst schnellen
Integration der Ukraine in die
westlichen Bündnisse spielen die USA
eine zentrale Rolle braucht die Ukraine
die Unterstützung der Vereinigten
Staaten kurz vor Weihnachten am 21
Dezember trifft Präsident selensky zu
seinem ersten Auslandsbesuch seit Beginn
der russischen Invasion in Washington
ein er kommt direkt von der Front in
bachmut in der Ostukraine er will sich
für die amerikanische Unterstützung
bedanken Held unter großen Beifall eine
Rede vor dem US-Kongress in der
Abgeordneten und Senatoren noch einmal
deutlich macht worum es für die Ukraine
geht
[Applaus]
ich weiß dass alles von uns von den
ukrainischen Streitkräften abhängt
aber es hängt auch so viel von der Welt
ab und so vieles in der Welt hängt von
Ihnen ab
als ich gestern in bachmut war gaben wir
unsere Helden diese Fahne die kampfhahne
derer die die Ukraine Europa und die
Welt unter Einsatz ihres Lebens
verteidigen
diese Flagge ist ein Symbol für unseren
Sieg in diesem Krieg wir stehen wir
kämpfen und wir werden siegen denn wir
sind vereint Ukraine Amerika und die
gesamte freie Welt
silensky trifft den richtigen Ton weiß
dass bei den amerikanischen Abgeordneten
die eigene Geschichte mitschwingt wenn
er vom Kampf für Freiheit und
Unabhängigkeit spricht und er weiß auch
dass er die USA auf seiner Seite hat
wenn es um eine schnelle Integration der
Ukraine die westlichen Bündnisse geht
die Menschen in der Ukraine kämpfen den
Kampf der NATO seit 1945 ist es
amerikanische Politik das Frieden und
Stabilität auf dem europäischen
Kontinent in Amerikas Interesse liegt
deshalb haben wir die NATO gegründet und
nur weil die Ukraine kein Mitglied der
NATO ist bedeutet das nicht dass ihr
Überleben als freies und unabhängiges
Land nicht auch die NATO betrifft das
tut uns
Präsident George Bush hat im April 2008
auf dem NATO-Gipfel in Bukarest
vorgeschlagen die Ukraine und Georgien
im Schnellverfahren in die NATO
aufzunehmen das wäre richtig gewesen
doch Deutschland und Frankreich waren
dagegen ich glaube dass es 2014 keine
Invasion gegeben hätte wenn die Ukraine
schnell der NATO beigetreten wäre
die Ukraine nicht schnell in die NATO
aufzunehmen sei ein schwerer
strategischer Fehler gewesen vor allem
der Europäer der jetzt in der Ukraine
mit viel Blut und Leid bezahlt werde die
halbherzige Reaktion des Westens dann
auf die russische Annexion der Krim und
Teile der Ostukraine 2014 aber Russland
weiter ermuntert seine imperialen
Fantasien mit Gewalt durchsetzen zu
wollen was zu dem Angriff auf die
Ukraine im vergangenen Februar führt
[Musik]
die westliche Reaktion auf die Annexion
der Krim war völlig unzureichend sehr
schwach es gab ein paar Sanktionen gegen
die Russen ich denke der Kreml hat das
Fehlen einer wirksamen westlichen
Reaktion als Duldung interpretiert wir
hätten viel stärkere Sanktionen schon
für die erste Invasion verhängen soll
die Leute haben gesagt wenn wir
Sanktionen verhängen könnten die Russen
einmarschieren nun sie sind ein
marschiert wie hätte es also noch
schlimmer kommen können
New York City Hauptsitz der Vereinten
Nationen aus den Trümmern der Zerstörung
geschockt von den bestialischen Groll
der beiden Weltkriege im vergangenen
Jahrhundert hatte sich die Welt 1945 mit
Gründung der Vereinten Nationen ein
gemeinsames Regelwerk gegeben und sich
versprochen das so etwas nie wieder
passieren dürfen
Anfang 2022 ringt der UN-Sicherheitsrat
darum Russland von einem Überfall auf
die Ukraine abzuhalten in einem
Interview mit dem russischen Propaganda
Medium RT behauptete russische
Außenminister love am 10 Februar 2022
das Russland nicht vorhabe in die
Ukraine einzumarschieren alles
Propaganda und falschnachrichten des
Westens
nur zwei Wochen später kommt der
UN-Sicherheitsrat am Abend des 24
Februar auf drängende Ukraine seiner
Dringlichkeitssitzung zusammen der
ukrainische UN-Botschafter erklärt
russland habe den Angriff begonnen sei
in sein Land einmarschiert
es ist die Verantwortung dieser
Organisation den Krieg zu stoppen
ich rufe sie auf alles zu tun um diesen
Krieg zu stoppen
ein Jahr ist seitdem vergangen wir haben
uns mit dem ukrainischen un-botschafters
Sergej kisslicia in der ukrainischen
Vertretung in New York verabredet sehr
gekislicia ist Karriere Diplomat war
stellvertretender Außenminister seines
Landes wir treffen ihn am großen
Konferenz des der Vertretung die
Vereinten Nation sagt er uns sein an
ihrer wichtigsten Aufgabe gescheitert
die un-kater sagt dass es die erste
Aufgabe der UN ist
Kriege zu verhindern
leider hat die UN versagt
der UN-Sicherheitsrat handlungsunfähig
weil der Aggressor Russland als Veto
macht alle Resolutionen verhindert die
ein Ende der Kampfhandlungen und den
sofortigen Rückzug Russlands aus der
Ukraine fordern
stattdessen nutzt der russische
Botschafter den Sicherheitsrat als große
Bühne um offensichtliche Lügen
Desinformation und Propaganda zu
verbreiten
bombardieren keine ukrainischen Städte
wir haben gesagt dass sie nicht bedroht
sind es gibt keine verifizierbare
Bestätigung über den Tod von Zivilisten
die von der Ukraine präsentierten
zivilen Opfer sein geschminkte
Schauspieler die USA und die Ukraine
würden an kampfzugvögeln und
kampffledermäusen arbeiten die nur für
slawische Menschen gefährliche Biowaffen
transportieren würden besonders perfide
auch seine Version der Gräueltaten von
Butcher
wir sehen hier die kriminelle
Inszenierung ukrainischer Zivilisten die
von radikalen getötet wurden um in
bester Goebbels Manier die russische
Armee zu beschuldigen
das wichtigste Gremium der Vereinten
Nationen der UN-Sicherheitsrat ist
völlig handlungsunfähig weil eine Veto
macht das System hat seine Geiseln nimmt
die nicht mehr in der Lage ist ihre
Aufgabe zu erfüllen mehr und mehr werden
Abstimmungen aus dem Sicherheitsrat in
die UN-Generalversammlung verlegt hier
wird mit Mehrheit entschieden Vetos sind
nicht möglich
am zweiten März 2022 verurteilen 141
Staaten den russischen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine nur vier Länder stimmen mit
Russland Syrien Weißrussland Eritrea und
Nordkorea
ein großer Erfolg für die Ukraine und
doch kaum mehr als ein politisches
Stimmungsbild denn Resolutionen der
UN-Generalversammlung sind
völkerrechtlich nicht bindend und große
einflussreiche Länder wie Indien
Südafrika und China enthalten sich
das ganze UN-System sei marode meint der
ehemaliger amerikanische unbotschafter
John Bolten
die UN-Generalversammlung ist reine
Zeitverschwendung und der Sicherheitsrat
kann keine bedeutsamen Entscheidungen
treffen den Russland und China werden
sie mit einem Veto belegen das ist in
der un-struktur angelegt und wird sich
nicht ändern
die alte Weltordnung zerbricht und eine
neue wird entstehen so wie es immer war
in der Geschichte nach dem großen
menschheitskatastrophen die Vereinten
Nationen sind in ihrer Organisationsform
so wohl am Ende
der Völkerbund wurde nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg gegründet die Vereinten
Nationen wurden nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg gegründet
und jetzt haben wir einen Konflikt den
wir nur mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
vergleichen können
und wenn dir keine Lehren aus diesem
Konflikt ziehen wenn wir zur
Tagesordnung übergehen wenn wir Russland
militärisch besiegt haben dann wäre das
das Dümmste was wir tun können
dass der russische Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine hier in den Vereinten Nationen
beendet wird an einem Ort an dem
Russland mit seinem Veto alles
blockieren kann ist praktisch nicht mehr
vorstellbar
denn dass ich die Ukraine russischen
Forderungen nach Neutralität und
Gebietsabtretungen unterwirft sei nach
all der Zerstörung und dem Leiters
Russland in der Ukraine angerichtet habe
völlig ausgeschlossen
die Regierung der Ukraine gegen den
Willen von 80 bis 90% der Ukraine unter
Druck zu setzen bedeutet Chaos zu
stiften
ein Land das sich im Chaos befindet kann
sich nicht selbst verteidigen auch nicht
mit Hilfe der Alliierten das würde eine
Invasion der Ukraine bedeuten die
Ukraine wäre nach all den Anstrengungen
nach all den Bemühungen der Verbündeten
geopfert nur um Putin ein Geschenk zu
machen
und ihm eine Plattform zu bieten um die
baltischen Staaten Polen und so weiter
anzugreifen
wir wollten auch dem russischen
UN-Botschafter die Gelegenheit geben und
seine Sicht zu schildern
unsere Interviewanfragen aber wurden
noch nicht einmal beantwortet
[Musik]
gabrielius Landsbergs hat uns in seiner
Heimatstadt nach Vilnius eingeladen
damit wir verstehen was ihn und viele
Osteuropäer antreibt woher die Angst
kommt als es 1991 in Litauen um die
Unabhängigkeit ging haben sie das
Parlament mit Barrikaden vor russischen
Panzern geschützt die waren nicht weit
entfernt
dahinten drei Kilometer entfernt sind
viele gestorben die russischen Panzer
überrollten die Menschen
hatten sich bereits tausende vor dem
Parlament versammelt
[Applaus]
das Parlament war für barricardiert ganz
viele Kameras übertrugen die Bilder in
die Welt
es war klar ein Angriff wäre ein
Massaker gewesen
der Kampf gegen die Aggression der
Russen ist das Lebensthema seiner
Familie
sein Großvater wie tautas Landsbergs war
damals Präsident und führte den
Widerstand an
er sein Enkel war neun Jahre alt und
spürt wieder die Angst
alle in Vilnius konnten die Panzer hören
es ist doch nur eine kleine Stadt und
die russischen Panzer sind so groß
es sind dieselben Panzer die sie jetzt
in der Ukraine benutzen
wir schauen uns gemeinsam die Aufnahmen
von damals an vom Meer als 30 Jahren
nie wieder Opfer sein das
überlebensmotto der Litauer
wie sein Großvater organisiert er den
Widerstand diesmal für die Ukraine in
Litauen sie die nächsten zu sein
wenn wir uns nicht wehren mal sehen wer
der nächste sein wird denn wir sind so
nah
100 Kilometer entfernt von der
Hauptstadt Vilnius an der Grenze zur
russischen Enklave Kaliningrad der
Stacheldraht Zaun ist neu durch Europa
geht ein neuer eiserner Vorhang
der kleine Ort panemone ist die letzte
litauische Stadt vor der Grenze auf der
anderen Seite liegt der westliche
Ausläufer Russlands nicht weit von hier
sind auf einem russischen
Militärstützpunkt
atomwaffenfähige Raketensysteme
stationiert Victoria palliokine hält
hier die Stellung über Politik darf sie
nicht reden aber sie will uns zeigen wie
nah Russland ist da hinten verläuft die
Grenzlinie genau in der Mitte der Schnee
verdeckt sie gerade
die Brücke gehört den Russen früher
trennte panemone und Kaliningrad nur der
Fluss nun ist drüben der Feind wer
verteidigt die Grenze bei einer Invasion
fragen wir sie
und dann muss sie selbst lachen und geht
zurück auf ihren Posten
die Grenze trennt Familien nur noch
wenige passieren sie sie ist Litauerin
ihre kranke Mutter ist Russin und lebt
auf der anderen Seite der Brücke in
Kaliningrad über den Krieg will sie nur
eins sagen
keiner will Krieg auch meine Eltern
nicht wir hoffen alle auf Frieden aber
was können wir einfach Leute schon
machen
ein großes Set prangt seit Kriegsbeginn
auf der Häuserwand auf der russischen
Seite den Litauen macht dies Angst viele
russische Panzer in der Ukraine haben
das gleiche Zeichen sie empfinden das
als Thron
die russische Fahne jeden Tag das weckt
bei mir sehr schlimme Gedanken ich habe
meinen Verwandten drüben in Kaliningrad
geschrieben ob sie dort nicht einen
Protest organisieren können das Zelt zu
entfernen aber ich habe nie eine Antwort
erhalten wahrscheinlich haben sie den
Brief zensiert alles wird da drüben
zensiert
früher war es hier voll saß mir Russen
und Litauer zusammen nun sitzen hier nur
noch die Polizisten und grenzschütze
Regina spürt die Angst der Menschen
einige wollen weg ihr Sohn lebt in
England
wir reden viel über die Angst vor einem
Angriff
bisher machen wir Witze darüber wir
haben einen sehr guten Keller dort
würden wir uns verstecken der Keller hat
dicke Wände
januar treffen wir noch einmal Jana die
Ukrainerin die in Brüssel lebt und sich
für ihr Land einsetzt auf der
Demonstration hat sie uns von ihrem
Vater erzählt der an der Front ist und
auf Panzer wartet
sie sitzt bei sich zu Hause vor dem
Fernseher da kommt die Nachricht
Deutschland sei bereit Leopard Panzer zu
liefern jeden Tag fürchtet sie um das
Leben ihres Vaters nun ist sie
erleichtert die Panzer sollen ihn und
seine Kameraden schützen
mein Vater ist in einer schwierigen
Situation er ist an der Front er hat
keine Zeit Nachrichten zu schauen wenn
ich das nächste mal mit ihm telefoniere
sage ich ihm die Kampfpanzer kommen und
es wird noch mehr Unterstützung geben
das macht mich glücklich
sie will noch ihrer Mutter in der
Ukraine die frohe Botschaft überbringen
die hat nur eine Stunde Strom deshalb
ist es gar nicht so einfach in
Kriegszeiten den Kontakt zu halten
ich habe es gerade im Fernsehen gesehen
die Deutschen geben die Erlaubnis Panzer
zu liefern
das ist so gut so wunderbar danke
Deutschland dafür vielleicht Jana haben
sie euren Protest mit den Stofftier
Leoparden gesehen und verstanden
zurück nach Vilnius grade sind die
Entscheidungen zu den Kampfpanzern
gefallen da fordert Landsbergs weitere
Waffen Kampfjets er zeigt uns sein Star
Wars Plakat Putin stehe auf der dunklen
Seite der Macht er sei Luke Skywalker er
hofft dass auch im richtigen Leben das
Gute siegt dazu braucht es eben die
richtigen Waffen
das nächste was wir brauchen sind
Langstrecken
die müssen die Amerikaner liefern aber
Kampfjets wären auch die richtige
Botschaft
den Namen Landsbergs haben sie auf den
Barrikaden verewigt um den Kampf seines
Großvaters gegen die Russen zur Ehren
das ist das Erbe das ihn antreibt